you popped the question
you got down on one knee i need all the
details everybody was so excited when we
saw it on social media so
congratulations thank you give us the
details all the planning and everything
that went in behind sure um
you know i i decided to do it in oxford
mississippi there's a venue there called
the lyric
um it's like a small 800 to a thousand
cap venue and that's where she and i met
around four years ago and so a few
months ago i decided i wanted to do it
there and i wanted to if i could do it
exactly like in the spot where we met
and um so that's what we did and a few
months ago i was able to i played a show
with dustin lynch his pool party thing
that he did in vegas
and
her parents came out to that but she
didn't come so it was a really good time
to ask her dad you know for permission
and all that so it really all worked out
perfectly and as soon as i got his
permission i went and bought the ring
and i held on to it for a couple months
and then i faked a private gig uh in
oxford the day after my atlanta show
this past weekend and um it just worked
out it she as far as i know she was she
was pretty fooled and
and um
you know there were obviously we walk
inside and there was no private gig and
and uh some of my man my management and
and a few other people helped set it up
with the rose petals and everything so
it worked out
were you more nervous to ask her dad
than anything that you'd ever ask before
in your life you know not really he's a
very um
he's he's such a cool guy and just and
and i just felt super comfortable and
like our families love each other so it
was very
not intimidating you know i'm still i
will always be somewhat scared to death
of him a little bit but uh
but for the most part no it was i was
more excited than anything the only time
i got nervous was when we got off my bus
and we were walking into the venue
to go propose and and she had no idea
and like the ring is in my back pocket
and like i had to walk behind her the
whole time because i didn't want to see
it anyway that was the only time that i
got a little bit nervous but really more
than anything just excited so it's been
almost one year now since you released
your debut album a rock can we expect
morning music soon how is the next album
coming along um
yes i can't really talk about too much
but
something really cool is happening
pretty soon and uh
and also uh
something else really cool is happening
really soon i can't really talk about
either one of them right now but uh yes
always i
feel like i'm always doing something or
getting in the studio to do something so
uh yeah before the end of the year there
will definitely be a lot of new music
out there